this past weekend the super duper epic
blast premiere fall finals came to a
close
and by god is there a lot to talk about
blame and config are bringing astralis
back heroic are most definitely not
onliners faze are
on the brink of something great
simple remains a divinity and bit is
pretty much the greatest rookie in the
history of cs go
while vitality's last dance somehow
brought an end to navi's nuke streak and
that's not even touching on the clutches
the crowd and the rumored roster
shuffles
there's a lot to talk about in the world
of counter-strike
so let's get into it
[Music]
all right it's youtube so you know the
deal like the video subscribe to the
channel and if you are into these
counter-strike related donators as much
as i am turn on notifications
i genuinely live to do these and the
support you guys have shown is
overwhelming so for real
thank you okay i don't want to start
getting all misty-eyed so i'll move on
to the good stuff
well i do like i do want to cry but not
because y'all are beauties i want to cry
because
rav
that crowd was won for the ages thank
you fine denisons of denmark and all
visitors in attendance for making this
event so
outrageously unremittingly hype the
danes live and die for counter-strike we
know this but even by their insane
awesome viking standards this was
something else this audience was on one
and so were the casters i think we can
all agree that scrawny and launders
really stepped up for this one can you
let me
hear you roar
[Applause]
so what were they on about
well for starters the thing that they're
always on about
astralis thanks to blame f and config
who are apparently just the next best
duo in counter-strike astralis are
seemingly back before they ever even
really left
they sonic slawed heroic on mirage
before dumpstering them on nuke and hear
me out i think
think that lucky may have been born to
rifle after all that said it was
definitely config who consistently stole
the show for those who don't know he
left complexity with a hand injury
underwent surgery and then just showed
up on land and started smurfing look
it's no secret that n a matchmaking is a
literal dumpster fire right now
thing is after taking like a year and a
half off and getting rank decayed back
into mg i've decided that i'm actually
gonna try to get back to a rank with
some form of black on it and at this
point i'm willing to try anything
so here goes okay you can do this think
of all the cheaters you're gonna face
think of all the silvers you're gonna
beat without ranking up changing
sensitivities has gotten you nowhere
rezzes are for cowards you tried to
outrun this moment but the time is wait
wait wait wait wait wait hold on
this is ridiculous
i'm not gonna break my hand just for
some free mmr like that's insane
i'll just
cue on the eu servers the question of
course is whether astralis are so nasty
that provided that nip continues to not
really be able to field a roster that
can stand up next to device he actually
comes back to astralis and takes lucky's
spot now i got nothing against lucky
this kid is an animal and performed like
one all weekend
but it's device like think how sick that
would be oh and speaking of danish
insanity shout out to cadian for being a
literal [ __ ] demon during his
pop-offs i think heroic may need to hire
an actual exorcist to keep this absolute
legend in check i do think heroic
probably should have beaten astralis and
if they'd actually managed to close out
mirage would have but still a decent
showing from a roster who some are
dubbing a kryptonite in the making for
navi speaking of kryptonite of all the
rosters to end navi's once never-ending
nuke streak who would have thought it
would be the last gasp of the all french
vitality it's bit with the first
headshot a little bit of a snap from
simple bit he's got it three at least
zaiwu all that remains and with 10
seconds left on the clock he's going to
prioritize plant they're looking down
swarming all around him he gets himself
into a little bit of cover too
no way
one final dance from vitality they still
lost the series of course but what a
showing from these soon-to-be fragmented
frenchies the boy zywoo and misuta both
went huge and with sonic and dupree and
magisk reportedly making their way into
the roster quite soon
very promising of things to come are you
proud of what you've managed to achieve
for this final time on land in front of
a crowd yeah of course we are really
proud the team is really proud like we
played really good cs
and
it was overcrowded
for the 2029 the last event so yeah we
are really proud
and going into 2022 what's the goal for
zai wu it's a goal i don't know let's
see like maybe you win a match or one
major maybe
i don't know of course what everyone
really walked away from this weekend
talking about is navi and the era of
dominance that they have definitely
undoubtedly 100 this time ushered in but
bits right here he stops it sprays away
the deep news comes long
this may be vitality's coffin but it's
navi's castle
the kings of counter-strike defend their
crowns inside the royal arena
every time they win something the slam
the major now blast everyone myself
included always says the same thing okay
now we're in the navi era but it really
seems as if after this weekend it isn't
up for debate anymore navi are without
question the best roster in the world
this is their era simple of course
remains inhuman and i'm sure you're all
sick of hearing me talk about him so i
won't but i gotta say this kid bit is on
another level easily the greatest rookie
cs go has ever seen what else
oh phase
phase
i feel like phase are one move away from
being truly nasty there isn't much to
say other than with twists back to his
usual insane form and olaf being
succeeded by
say
rob's eye emoji
i feel like this phase could live up to
the super team of old of course the only
other thing to talk about are the
rumored roster moves which i won't
really dive into until announcements
start becoming a little bit more
official i will say that it does seem as
if nitro's return to cs is all but
confirmed as reported by onepv's nell
which we obviously love to see he's been
running a ton of fpl apparently and is
well on his way to shaking the rust off
i imagine in fact i happened to queue
into a retake server with him last
weekend and took it as an opportunity to
pay the liquid squad of old a little
tribute yo nature i'm gonna call zero
this guy
just for you homie of course there are
tons of other moves on everyone's mind
as well the rest of the liquid rebuild
rumors of stew and tim to eg
monasty to g2 but we'll have no idea
what's real and what's not until things
start becoming a little more official
until then thank you for tuning in and
i'll see you next time
i think that i'm gonna actually take
some of the old videos colton's gonna
appreciate this shout out we used to do
really really intricate skits
in the office and like oh my god man the
lengths that colton in particular used
to go to to make these skits i remember
one time he set up a black and white
horror movie downstairs and like he
literally put black sheets on all the
walls and all the windows and he shot
like a [ __ ] neo noir interrogation
scene like with the light in the face
and like the bogart style like this
stuff that we used to do was absolutely
insane like he would be like hey i have
to go film a scene after the [ __ ]
melty blood auditions golden had to go
out by a dumpster in the freezing cold
and put like a sign of oh man like he's
gonna know all this stuff i'm talking
about